tél en attendant les deux candidats
poursuivent leur marathon mais sans
meeting aujourd'hui ayant tout d'abord
la journée de françois mitterrand qui a
fait des propositions pour les personnes
âgées dans leur a dit non
monsieur françois mitterrand alfortville
est appuyé par joseph wrésinski le maire
socialiste et moment plus émouvant par
la chorale du troisième raconte walter
devant les pensionnaires monsieur
mitterrand rappelle ses propositions
pour un meilleur troisième âge dans
l'autonomie et la dignité parmi les 10
premières droit à la retraite à 60 ans
augmentation du minimum vieillesse à 17
cents coups de 1000 francs par mois pour
le rapprocher de celui
revalorisation des rentes viagères ainsi
que plusieurs mesures d'ordre financier
monsieur mitterrand a présenté ensuite
je fais chat pendant à ce niveau visant
à garde les autres et propositions la
première consiste à développer la
politique de maintien à domicile les
personnes âgées veulent souvent vivre
chez elles elles ont raison et pour
favoriser le maintien à domicile il faut
des personnes et foi personnelle sociale
les travailleuses familiales
les aides-ménagères
aussi je propose de créer vingt mille
emplois des aides ménagères et de
développer les services de soins à
domicile dans le cadre du recrutement
des 210 mines al jean dont j'ai déjà
parlé dans le cadre des premières
propositions ou plutôt décision que je
prendrai il faut aussi représenter les
retraités dans les instances qui les
concernent caisses de retraite caisses
d'assurance-maladie conseil économique
et social conseil des maisons de
retraités il faut troisièmement
reconnaître le droit à l'éducation
permanente alors que les ressources de
la formation permanente bénéficient
seulement aujourd'hui aux actifs enfin
dernier point il convient d'ouvrir à
tous les équipements collectifs sociaux
et culturels et incitation au
rapprochement familial
logement transport
l'ouvrir à tous vous entendez sans
exception afin de faire renaître la
relation sociale essentielle grands
parents petits enfants et puis
généralement entre personnes âgées et
jeunes enfants
françois mitterrand qui a fait répondre
oui aux douze propositions formulées par
brice lalonde il ya des divergences a
dit socialiste paul quilès mais il me
semble qu'elles sont faibles